we're in Germany's Motor City Stuttgart
a Daimler press spokesman drives up with
our next test car morning good morning
hey guys dr. Vetter I know that hello
yes the be 250 e it's our B class with
an all-electric drive it makes almost no
sacrifices you've got the same space in
the trunk and five seats just like any
other B Class got a stupid question
what's in these things that's not a
stupid question
unlike the combustion engine model it's
got a charging port here and we've got a
cable to go with it one for a wall box
drive off without cables and for a
normal socket very good and what can we
say about these cables on a socket it
takes all night to charge and with this
charging system you can fully charge
from the wall box in two and a half
hours doesn't it tell me to leave the
road and recharge no doesn't all those
dude smart and the BMW i3 both told me
that the sat-nav shows filling stations
but no charging stations
oh that's practical Mercedes like Metis
what do I need gas stations for when I'm
driving an electric car the sat-nav
should point the way to an a charging
station not gas stations
we have a journey of about 400
kilometres ahead from Stuttgart to the
Saarland given a range of just under 200
kilometers per charge our trip has to be
well planned electric motorists all
around Germany are networked online and
provide valuable tips on sites like
going electric de as if you know we've
unpacked our laptop out in the Prairie I
think this will help us more than
Mercedes navigation system this website
shows is exactly where we can charge the
car what the charging capacities are and
whether the stations free and working I
hope that'll get us where we're going
because unfortunately Mercedes sat-nav
wouldn't have that understand see what
we've worked out our route online
that'll give a sufficient opportunity to
juice up charging is a new experience
every time you never know what will
happen now I'll connect the cable
Econoline statement
father is charging smiley one extended
lunchbreak later now let's see if the
car is fully charged after two hours
we've got what batteries only half full
from 75 kilometers worth of power two
and a half hours of charging for another
25 kilometers I don't believe it the
stuff that we need violins I'm uh
I won't drive faster than 20 the next
dog can't be farm there's supposed to be
a charging pole in vine high near
Heidelberg Christian we only have 36
kilometers I don't know where we can go
but I'm sure it won't be this our aunty
who have to find a charging station
there's supposed to be one there by no
one's seen a charging station for a cars
have you ever seen an e-card charging
station Christian we can get horses here
maybe a carriage but there's no charging
station but here's the city hall maybe
we're in luck is that the pole no that's
the charging station Christian this is
not looking good for us what kind of
thing is that it's attached to a mobile
streetlight I don't even know if it's
hooked up to the grid that's got okay
well vegetable probably don't cut no
woman I guess it has to be the charging
station has power the problem is that
this b-class doesn't take it up very
fast six now we've got 36 kilometres
range after five minutes we've got one
additional kilometre five minutes one
kilometre we need 200 kilometres
we've only got 36 that'll take
normally we should reach full capacity
much faster but as the saying goes
strength lies in calmness we left the B
Class Mercedes hooked up for five hours
ninety nine kilometers
yes 99 km/h for there is another
charging pole and then we can spend
another four hours charging there to get
to our destination in the sauerland
tomorrow so amenities company ok night
driving in the next installment will be
taking the B Class onto the Autobahn at
night but will we make it all the way to
the solid